et pour nous un problème important ce
qui je pense qu'il faut se mettre à la
place du de l'utilisateur quand on
déploé une zone en fibre optique
globalement on va dire 80% des 4,75 80 %
des personnes qui sont dans cette zone
en fibre optique vont prendre sur
quelques années le un abonnement la
fibre optique spontanément ça ça va être
quelque chose d'extrêmement facile
simple ils vont avoir l'intérêt quand
ils vont déménager mon pauvre demander
de l'ADSL naturellement ils vont prendre
de la fibre et c'est quelque chose
d'accepter on a une dizaine de % des
foyers dans lesquels il va falloir
travailler et expliquer et on va réussir
à les convaincre et puis on a les
irréductibles qui représentent en
fonction des zones 10 à 15% des foyers
et saisir réductibles
c'est pas qu'ils aiment la DSL c'est que
ça marche ils ne veulent pas que ça
bouge il faut que ça soit stabilisé et
le seul moyen le seul élément qui va
permettre de les faire basculer c'est
l'extinction du cuivre on l'a vu à
levi-sins noms la vue à certains
endroits où on a fait des
expérimentations les seuls moments où
cela fonctionne c'est quand on dit voilà
demain il n'y a plus de cuivre il va
falloir basculer à la fibre optique et
c'est le seul moment dans lequel
ça marche et je pense que collectivement
doit avoir un but c'est d'éteindre le
plus rapidement possible ce réseau
en cuivre déjà parce que ça va réduire
l'impact environnemental puisque avoir
deux raisons en parallèle ça n'a pas
environnemental
double voire même un peu plus puisque le
cube est extrêmement consommateur
d'énergie et puis ça veut dire aussi
optimiser l'investissement puisque quand
on a déployé ces réseaux de fibres
optiques plus ils sont plein plus ils
sont remplis plus notre investissement
et rentabiliser et rentabilisé pardon